how we doing people i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message for
today march 17th 2022 we are live
streaming on rumble youtube and blaze tv
obviously uh yesterday was a day of uh
an awful lot of love sent our way it was
it was a really interesting day you know
talking about these two babies and
expanding our family and everything else
and you know got personal in a way that
maybe i don't always get personal here
uh doing the political thing all the
time
um and i'm i'm sort of overwhelmed and i
can speak for david and i can speak for
pretty much everyone in our family is
sort of overwhelmed by the amount of
love and well wishes there was some uh
some negativity too uh this is the
internet and i don't know if you know
this but it's not always just an
endlessly joyous happy place uh and i
want to address some of the good stuff
and and some of the negativity and we're
going to do that in the q a uh in just a
few minutes uh the big news today around
here though is that the pre-sale
for the don't burn this country book
tour the pre-sale is up now so first off
you can get the book right now at
daverubin.com
book and we've got the links there for
all the places that you can purchase the
book barnes noble amazon your local
bookstores etc etc but the pre-sale for
the tour is up right now at
reubenreport.locals.com it'll be out for
the general public tomorrow but we
wanted early access for my locals
community uh do we have the image of the
uh the tourist stops can we throw up the
old tour stop image there we go we're
gonna be in orlando west palm clearwater
we'll be in raleigh north carolina
atlanta chicago dallas washington west
nyack new york break california oxnard
san jose phoenix and denver this is just
sort of the first run of the tour so
right now if you want to buy tickets
today and we'll do meet and greets i'll
take selfies you can shake my hand you
can do limited hugs you know the one
second hug again my feelings about the
over two second hug it starts getting
weird uh all of that good stuff uh the
tickets are available today for the
local community so you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com and the info is
all there and then the tickets will be
available for the general public
tomorrow
um and i'm excited i'm excited to get
back out there and
meet the people see the people see
smiling faces chat with you guys we'll
do a q a i'm going to bring uh some
guests on for some of the shows so rumor
has it glenn beck will be joining me for
one perhaps the dallas show i'm hearing
dennis prager is going to join me one
perhaps the brea show we're working on
larry elder i think megan mccain
possibly megan kelly a couple other
people so it's going to be fun i'll do
like an hour talk and mess around with
you guys we'll do a little q a let you
guys ask some questions let the guest
ask some questions it's gonna be fun i'm
psyched and i'm looking forward to it
alright we got a million questions here
and i want to do one quick story up top
about kyrie irving because the guy
brooklyn netstar kyrie irving the guy
scored 60 points on tuesday on a road
game he plays for the nets and then they
wouldn't let the guy freaking uh play
back in new york city literally the next
night that's how stupid all these covet
rules are but before we get to that i
want to talk to you about z stack you
know if the last two years have taught
us anything it's that you must take
control of your own health it's clear
that you can't simply rely on the
government or big pharma to protect you
or your family that's where z stack
comes in z stack is especially
formulated immune boosting supplement
that includes zinc quercetin vitamin c
and vitamin d formulated by dr vlad
zelenko the world-renowned doctor that
president trump credited with his
successful early treatment protocol and
his decision to take hcq zstack has been
scientifically formulated is kosher and
gmp certified and is produced right here
in the good old u.s of a although mass
mandates are being lifted and vaccine
mandates are no longer enforced in
several states hallelujah viruses are
still out there by taking z-stack daily
you're supercharging your immune system
z-stack is formulated to help help
combat any and all variants as well as
the common cold and the flu i encourage
you to start taking it now and stay
ahead of any potential future variants
by preparing your immune system and go
about living your life go to
zstacklife.com today
dave
enter code dave and you're going to get
a little discount off your first order
that zstacklife.com
dave promo code dave all right so first
i just want to do one story because i
this is just so indicative of how stupid
that's the only word for it like how
absolutely stupid everything has become
so kyrie irving is an nba player he's a
pretty darn good player multiple time
all-star he's bounced around on a couple
teams got close to a championship a
couple times hasn't hasn't gotten it yet
he's playing for the brooklyn nets now
and he decided that he did not want to
get vaccinated and he laid out his
opinions over the last couple months
which were similar to the opinions of
many other people basically saying hey i
take care of myself i'm young and
healthy i don't want to be forced into
anything
unfortunately as you guys know the nba
went really all in on vax mandates and
they had their players playing in a
bubble even though we know the bubble
was being pierced by all sorts of girls
that were let in at night and all kinds
of other things and i'm pretty sure
everyone in the nba is smoking weed 24
hours a day but that's a separate issue
altogether
we all understand that these rules don't
really make sense you've got players
that play on the court not wearing masks
then they're sitting on the bench with
one guy wearing a mask the coach wearing
a mask then they get into the team
huddle the guy takes the mask down the
other guy puts it on the audience the
fans half of them are wearing masks the
other fan the others aren't then they've
got it when they're not eating then they
take it down they're eating none of it
makes any sense but this
is just the perfect example of it so
kyrie irving scored 60
points on tuesday night on the road 60
points it was an nba season high okay 60
points it had just been hit the season
high a couple days before and then he
matched it all right 60 points that's a
lot of points you don't have to be a big
basketball fan to understand 60 is a lot
okay
then the next night when he was home in
new york he was unable to play because
he's unvaccinated
take a
look are we unable to play this
afternoon and
because of the
city ordinance
he's unable to play but he can walk into
the barclays center on madison don't get
it either and listen the nba and the
nbpa
you know
have been advised by their medical
experts that he can safely participate
in home games and obviously the hope is
that he will be able to yes at some
point
i hope
that if nothing changes from that
perspective and this is just a fan of me
talking not the of course not the person
who's you know
making these decisions i hope that
joe would pay the fine and the nba would
let him pay the fine
okay credit to the announcers they are
actually diving into the issues and not
shying away from the ridiculousness and
the hypocrisy um apparently you no
longer have to show a vax passport to be
a fan at one of those games so it's
unclear whether the people are vaxxed or
not vaxxed i don't care if they're
vaxxed or not backs if you don't want to
go out don't go out if you want to go to
a game and be vaccinated or not vaxxed
and wear a mask or not wear a mask
that's all up to you but i think you
guys get the level of abject
ridiculousness the guy is not sick he is
the peak of physical performance okay so
now the funny thing is i've been talking
a lot about bill maher on this show and
what's going on with these with these
liberals these lefties that sort of get
it but then don't get it and they never
vote the right way and what do we do
with these people and it's nice that
they're coming around but guys get to
the end of the road etc etc well trevor
noah who's the host of the daily show
and nobody really watches the daily show
anymore but these clips go seemingly
viral it's hard to tell if it's organic
or not but trevor noah was the host of
the daily show and he is you know this
is a guy that just you know a couple
weeks ago was calling for joe rogan to
basically be fired because he sent the
edward and he get he's wrong on pretty
much everything but even he even trevor
noah lefty wrong on everything trevor
noah sees the insanity of this kyrie
irving situation mayor eric adams has
lifted the rule that you have to be
vaccinated to attend indoor events okay
that's gone
but there is still a rule that you have
to be vaccinated to go to your workplace
so if someone's job is at an indoor
event they can't go to work but they can
show up to work
to watch their colleagues do their thing
yeah
which is exactly what happened this
weekend yeah guys i i don't care
like how coveted compliant you are like
this makes zero sense can we agree on
that
can we what so kyrie can go inside not
wear a mask even hug a teammate but he
cannot play
i don't get it why does the ball have a
weak immune system what's going on
i mean it's crazy just think about it
kyrie can't play but he can sit in the
stands right like a fan
and then as a fan what happens if he
gets picked to take the half court shot
to win the car can he do that what are
those
all right so putting aside that the
guy's just not funny he's got 20 writers
doing that whole thing okay fine that
but it's good to see i suppose someone
waking up however i think we're going to
see more and more of this as these rules
and regulations
are are so shown to be ridiculous and
nonsensical you're going to see more of
the liberals than the lefties who got
everything wrong for the last two years
starting to sound somewhat sane and the
question is what what do we kind of do
with them like do we everyone gets very
excited i see this happening all the
time every time a liberal says something
that's not completely like batshit
bananas everyone's like oh my god even
trevor noah and bill maher said it it's
like all right congratulations for being
two years too late to the party you guys
get my feelings on that here's trevor
noah trevor noah in october 2021 talking
about vaccine mandates in case you think
i'm making up that he's been wrong about
everything this whole time that's right
people vaccine mandates work
and if you ask me this is a win-win
situation yeah because think about it
it'll help keep everybody safe and it
gets the economy moving again and then
for the people who still didn't get
vaccinated
look i don't think you're right but if
you are
your win
is that we all die and then you guys
inherit the entire earth
it'll be pretty sweet for a while until
you all die of measles because you don't
believe in vaccines
right
because if you didn't believe in
mandates that means you don't believe in
vaccines so he was pushing mandates
government mandates on people we now
know that the vaccines did not work as
promised we know that there's all sorts
of side effects again everyone should do
whatever they want and talk to their
doctor but so i don't know i'm actually
asking you guys like i really am asking
you guys like what is it that we should
do in this situation should we keep you
know we want to keep coaching these
people to get the right way but he's
never going to get there right i think
there's a chance that bill maher will
get there but what do we do do we just
like oh my god you're so great because
you're not wrong a hundred percent of
the time or do we say no until until you
get there we just have to keep ignoring
you or mocking you or whatever i'm
really not sure what the answer is and
perhaps in next week's q a or you know
what during the live chat today maybe
with someone we'll have some comments on
that you can join the live chat which we
do every day during the show at
rubenford.locals.com
and now let's get to some community q a
uh gelaresh says dave is there any truth
to the rumor that you'll be naming your
children gavin and joe if boys or kamala
and alexandria if girls so first off
they are both boys um we went with the
strongest eggs the strongest embryos so
that was the choice there i would have
been happy if it was two girls david
would have been happy either way boy
girl two boys two girls we really didn't
care about that we wanted the strongest
viable
embryos uh and those happened to both be
male you cannot let the embryo choose
the sex uh it's just not a thing they
know the sex and that was it uh will i
go with joe what was it joe or who it
was joe
oh
oh gavin i mean i hate gavin newsom he's
on my top 10 list of people i hate uh it
will not be gavin it will not be joe i
don't mind the name joe actually but
gavin's a little smug or something or
i'm just so it's so associated with
gavin i kind of do like the name joe but
it will not be gavin or joe it and it's
not girls so it will not be kamala or
alexandria the name that i've been sort
of pushing i don't know if david wants
me to say this but the name that i've
been sort of i like the name brandon
i've always liked the name brandon and i
do think it would be just so cool to
have at least one of these kids i guess
you can't name them both brandon but you
name one kid brandon everywhere we go
let's go brandon like it would be like
just the greatest thing ever and it is a
good name so i gotta i gotta work on
david on that one uh but we're we
haven't decided yet we've got you know
we got a list and we're gonna try to
figure out and you know what actually
let me just get this out of the way
quick so i do want to just discuss some
of the
uh reaction
to uh the video that we did yesterday
and then the the pictures that we put on
social media about this um first off 99
of everything that uh was
sent to us uh emails
instagram comments twitter
what are the other things on social
media all the stuff uh was positive and
it was positive and overwhelmingly
positive and really just nice and
whatever and
loving and you know people are are happy
to see people expand their family even
if it's not the most traditional way of
doing things and i'm actually completely
respectful and understanding of people
seeing a situation like this and not
totally getting it i got to tell you as
somebody going through it myself and
going to fertility clinics and talking
to surrogates and talking to other
same-sex couples that have gone through
this like it's not the easiest thing in
the world i can understand why somebody
would think it's not the most
traditional thing in the world it
obviously isn't and i think we can have
all sorts of discussions about what the
family should look like and all of those
things but i saw a lot of people saying
you know that um not a lot of it wasn't
a lot of people actually it was a couple
people and then a lot of green griper
frogs or whatever they are on twitter
and some of these sort of like
catholic traditional they're all
anonymous accounts like there were a few
non-anonymous accounts but then there's
just tons of these anonymous accounts
and you know they say usually they just
say really horrible things but then
there were some things that people
brought up that were somewhat legitimate
like okay so is there going to be a
female role model in the house because
the role of a mother is important and i
completely agree with that david
completely agrees with that uh his mom
is going to live down here for for a bit
his sister is going to be here my sister
is here in miami my mom will be down
here i believe that a female
in the life of the child more than one
female is important i also think men and
women are different but in many ways
there are things that transcend your
your physical
whether you're a male or female there
are some men that are that are very very
nurturing right and there are some women
that just aren't and it has nothing to
do with sexuality david is very very
nurturing he really is he's a great
caregiver he is going to be giving all
of that to these kids i don't know that
i'm
me personally the best caregiver
especially in the early part but i'm
going to do the best that i can but
anyway i mention all of this because i
get
that this is it is a little bit
different so it's not you if if you are
watching this and you're going boy this
is a little bizarre i don't know a
couple like this like we know a couple
gay couples that have kids but i don't
know a ton of them and i'm sort of
treading this
uh this path i'm sort of blazing this
path in many ways on my own but i know
that we're going to do the best that we
can as parents regardless of our gender
and we just want these kids to be happy
and loved and live fulfilling lives uh
so when i see some of the the craziness
around this it's like okay so if you
guys
just want to go back a hundred years and
and things will be exactly as they were
it's not like things were so great a
hundred years ago and there's all sorts
of straight couples that are abusive or
the father leaves or the mother leaves
or parents are neglectful or alcoholics
there's there's no perfect thing here
but i can tell you that we're gonna do
the best that we can and for any of you
that are watching this that um think
this is a little
bizarre or out of the out of the norm
i'm i'm actually completely okay with
that and that's partly why
we even made a public acknowledgement of
this because it's like this is the
adventure that we're on i've tried to be
honest about my political adventure for
the last you know seven eight years
however long i've been doing this and
people have come along for the ride so
this will be another thing to come along
for the ride for and we will need all
sorts of of advice and help and and
the whole thing the whole thing
and that has nothing to do with
sexuality so those are my thoughts on
that
brad says regarding florida's
hb1557 what are your thoughts on
republicans going on the offense and
making democrats actually play their
cards and defend
sexualizing children look i think in
some ways this was probably
the florida legislatures and desantis's
calculation it's like if the left wasn't
always encroaching on everything right
like pushing woke-ism into the schools
taking out our educational institutions
and our corporate institutions and you
know being not racist is now racist all
the stuff that you know about if they
weren't always moving on everything
then there wouldn't be a need for a bill
like this a bill that basically just
says state workers can't talk to
kindergartners through third graders
through third graders about sex like
there would be no need for that if they
didn't feel this constant encroachment
so i sense that the legislature and i
don't know this for a fact i do not know
this for a fact
but i sense that the legislature and
desantis the calculation was let's let's
preempt some of this even though it's
obviously happening at some level in
schools like we see all the activist
teachers all the time on tick tock and
wherever else but let's preempt it a
little bit because the only way to
defend is to actually preempt
because they just keep moving that you
can't just wait until they're at your
door because then by the time they're at
the door they're actually basically
through the door right so the barbarians
are at the gate and i think the
legislature was like let's let's do
something to make them
be defensive so again this has nothing
to do with hating gay people it has
nothing to do with if there was a kid
who had two dads or two moms he's still
allowed to bring his parents to school
and everyone uh you can't demand that
parents be respectful of anybody
regardless of their sexuality but
there's nothing in there that the
parents can't come to school or should
be treated differently or anything else
it's about
state employees talking
to young young children about gender
identity and sexuality and then being
able to hide that from the parents and
if you if you're for that then that's on
you uh steve says is the war in ukraine
actually part two of the great reset
plan part one being covered lockdowns of
course yeah i think so i don't want to
sound like a crazy conspiracy theorist
but it's something like that you know
they they push two years of covet
insanity which now there's all sorts of
info that the lockdowns had no effect
other than they depressed us and got
people more hooked on drugs and
prescription pills and suicide went up
and people got fatter and all that
lockdowns didn't work all sorts of
evidence that masks didn't work
evidence that children's speech is
delayed i mean all of the societal and
social problems that came with these
draconian edicts that we allowed we
allowed it all of us allowed it
even those of us that fought it maybe we
should have fought harder i point
the finger at me on this one too maybe i
should have been screaming louder from
day one and i did scream a lot in the
last two years about this insanity but
what really is going on here it does
feel like the entire system
the system of western government of free
people of we the people that that are in
charge of the government not a
government that's in charge of us it
feels like that is being upended right
now and that's what the great reset is
all about it is not a conspiracy theory
i mean look at the world economic forum
stuff okay cloud schwab this is not
conspiracy this stuff this is stuff that
we should be talking about so i do sense
i mean the way they got us to pivot you
know that that state of the union
address two weeks ago we go through two
years of covet and lockdown and then he
barely mentions kovit until a half hour
in because we're talking about how we
have to save ukraine and what russia is
doing and it's like eye off the ball
there's we got our own problems here we
got supply chain problems and inflation
problems and immigration problems and
all of these things
and it does feel like they are trying to
in some ways crash the economy and have
gas prices rise so they can usher in
their their green new deal and electric
cars everywhere and and you know people
are talking about a digital currency i
don't know if this was just if this was
minority report we've got all the pieces
of the puzzle there and we're trying to
track this thing it's like we got to put
it together i think the best we can do
for now is keep talking about it and uh
and see but yeah i think there's
something there
drearier says just want to say that
rumble and locals are the only social
media platforms that haven't given into
the hysteria and ban russian sources uh
the ability to hear from all sides is
critical particularly in times of war
thank you for staying in such an amazing
company look the the goal of
us
merging us locals merging with rumble
was we felt that they were doing pretty
good on the free speech stuff um you
know duckduckgo as you know just in the
last week suddenly said that they are
going to reorder their search results
to
avoid russian misinformation and you
know who watches the watchers who
decides what
that misinformation actually is so
duckduckgo basically destroyed
its own company with with one sort of
silly tweet uh i've talked many times to
the ceo of rumble about this chris and
his belief is that we are a neutral
platform you can say what you want on
this platform it's not up to the
platforms to decide what is
misinformation and what isn't if they if
they were breaking specific laws if
there were threats and if they were
leaking information that could get
people hurt there's all things to talk
about with that
but from everything i know about what's
going on internally at rumble and locals
the the idea is we are neutral
and we will stay as neutral as humanly
possible that that's really where we're
at uh carol says did you hear about
jesse smollett's early release already
what are your thoughts on this i heard
about it this morning so he's staying in
jail for one week
is that right one week
just a few days after he gave his crazy
diatribe at the end of this thing that
he was innocent and if he killed himself
it wasn't him that killed himself
remember that he was supposed to be in
jail i think for a hundred
was it 150 days something like that and
they gave him one week so
congratulations jesse smoleta i don't
see how justice was served here in any
way i mean this guy poured so much
fuel on the racist fire burning in this
country a fire that we had just embers
left of there was there was really
almost no racism left it was not
accepted in any decent quarters and then
the workstars came in they they ignited
the fire again this guy poured fuel on
it the the mainstream media more fuel on
it and it's back unfortunately and he
gets one week for that something ain't
right emily says i can't wait to attend
your event in hotlanta thank you so much
for holding your ground and refusing to
go anywhere that requires vacs passports
or face mask face masks what's your
favorite part of doing the live events
it's just seeing people and i think for
this tour particularly in light of the
last two years like i'm really really
going to enjoy it i enjoy it when i go
to dinner and i see people now and i'm
at packed restaurants and you see people
and they're just out and about and life
does go on or at least it goes on here
in florida um you know it did cost us uh
some money and some headaches dealing
with the backs passports and the masks
and venues that i wouldn't do and that's
partially why we don't have a fully
robust list of stops yet because there
were so many things changing every day a
state was changing this the city was
changing this there were we had a couple
venues that didn't want to work with me
because i'm a right-wing maniac
apparently
so there's all sorts of stuff that we're
trying to figure out but we will add
more stops i know everyone's asking
about nashville we will do nashville
we're going to do some more stops in
texas and a bunch of others and it's
just it really is just being around the
people it's the live reaction
to the people uh that i miss more than
anything else and that's what i'm
looking forward to uh nissa says do you
follow
or read barry weiss i'd love to hear a
conversation between the two of you look
barry is welcome on this show uh you
know we we were sort of friendly for a
while she's the one that of course that
wrote that original idw piece in the new
york times and then left the new york
times because it had become so woke i
think she's sort of thrown a couple
people under the bus myself included
along her journey but no one does any of
this stuff perfectly
so barry if you're watching i'd be happy
to have this conversation i include her
in that bucket of sort of not completely
insane liberals that that bill maher
bucket and it's like all right if you're
gonna rail against this stuff eventually
you gotta vote the right way that's a
great conversation to have um so uh so
no i don't read her stuff really you
know occasionally it'll come across on
twitter or i'll see a little snippet or
something but i don't subscribe or
anything like that it's like if there's
a certain amount of people i think
there's a certain liberal intelligentsia
or something that just wants they just
want to keep writing things and and
always be behind on things or two years
late but then get applauded for it and
never really take a position when it's
unsafe to take so you know if you're
right now if you're you know she was on
uh bill maher about a month ago saying
how crazy lockdowns were and everything
else it's like yeah that was the
position a lot of us took two years ago
um you know the hunter biden story would
be a good one you know did you see just
today the new york times is now
basically saying yeah the hunter biden
emails they were all legit well many of
us were talking about it for a year at
least many of us were talking about it
before the election and remember new
york post got their twitter feed taken
down and if you posted about it on
social media you would get taken down
um so i would say i don't mean to make
this about her specifically but these
people it's like they'll start talking
about it now because now the new york
times said it was safe while they would
ignore or gladly throw the rest of us
under the bust for being conspiracy
theorists and crazy right-wingers so i'm
trying to arbitrage this situation as
you can see and welcome these people to
the same side but uh sometimes you gotta
drag people and sometimes people don't
want to be dragged them that's all right
uh you know are you gonna get uh you
know says are you gonna get a basketball
court at your new house we have a
basketball court i love it i'm out there
i try to be out there every day at least
for a few minutes shooting around or
playing horse with david i'm trying to
get this sunday game started with uh
with a bunch of local friends here in
miami although at the moment
i got a hip situation if any of you are
doctors masseuses something
literally two days ago out of nowhere
sharp pain in the hip did not do
anything
and the last two nights just stiff stiff
like it's it's aching right now so i
need some cbd or something and yeah
we'll figure it out but uh yeah i love
playing ball and
i guess if the nets won't have oh no i'm
unboxed too
i was gonna offer to play for the nets
but they won't have me and i could start
a team with kyrie let's get this to
kyrie you know
kyrie who who's on vax now still me
kyrie who else
uh jonathan isaac right jonathan isaac
on the orlando magic doesn't have to be
a ball player just give me a famous
people that are on backs who else is
there there's got to be somebody else
candace owens all right so i need one
more i need a starting five so we got
kyrie irving we got jonathan isaac on
the orlando magic we got dave rubin we
got candace owens uh bill maher's not
boosted no oh i don't think glenn beck
and uh and dennis prager never got it
all right that's a hell of a team dennis
prager is very tall can't play ball for
his life i took him out to my court once
it was it was really depressing
i'm gonna have a 65 year old guy who
smokes cigars every day candace owens
all right they got it kathy says have
you and david thought about schooling
your boys are you planning to homeschool
yeah we've talked about it a lot uh we
happen to live in an area where there
are pretty good
public schools um and and believe it or
not the public schools in florida by and
large are much much better than people
think they are there's the meme out
there that because florida doesn't have
state income tax that there isn't the
money to make the schools good but
that's it's a meme in that that's what
people think but the reality is it's not
just about money you know this is one of
the things that people like only if you
fund things to the tilt and always throw
more money at things that things will be
better florida has some really really
great public schools i don't see and
that being said
i don't see any way we're gonna send the
kids to public school i would be shocked
if we did but you know we've got a great
governor here who's doing a lot to clean
things up as much as possible so i would
say i'm in the one state that it could
be there is some realm of possibility
there you know there's private schools
there are charter schools a lot of
schools regardless of the state that
you're in and regardless of whether
they're catholic schools or jewish
schools or totally secular you know the
the woke thing has infected so many of
these schools right so
i sense we're probably going to
homeschool or do some sort of pod
situation with a few other kids
something like that david wants to be
really involved in that you know there's
a couple groups right now that are
really taking off that are figuring out
these pod situations where some days
you're at this person's house the next
day you're at this person's house small
groups a little more one-on-one
uh
a little more one-on-one direction to
the kid
so we'll see we'll see i really don't
know but we're thinking about it and
again it goes to where i started today
which is that we're going to do the best
we can to to raise kids that are sane
and decent and and know what's right and
wrong and the rest of it we'll see how
we do with that freedom fan says on a
scale of one to ten how difficult is it
for you that you have to be informed and
up to date on current events every
single day um
how difficult is it
well ten being the most difficult i'd
say it's
it's not in a certain way it's not that
difficult because i love this i really
do love this when i when i was a couple
weeks ago on the other side of florida
with with the family during president's
week and i wasn't doing shows like i'm
out there in the morning taking walks on
the beach like man there's so much going
on in the world i want to get back in
here and i really do love it and i love
interacting with you guys and all that
so in some ways even when the the news
is annoying i really do love this right
and there's so many ways that you can
talk about this stuff thoughtfully and
with some humor and all that so i love
that you know in a way i'm less
interested in politics than i've ever
been because i think politics is has
become a religion or more aptly a cult
for so many people that i'm not that
interested in oh you know 87 republicans
voted for this and 42 democrats voted
for that and you know and i you know you
can get frustrated with just like the
endless hypocrisy right you know all the
lockdown people that then party in
florida like aoc and the rest of them
swalwell etc so like there's a certain
level of frustration um you know talking
about covid especially since i've been
in florida is a little annoying because
it doesn't exist here in the sense that
people are just going on with their
lives
but i do sense that kovit2 is coming
probably right before the midterms so
that they can push mail in voting on
everybody um
you know the ukraine russia thing has
been interesting because i obviously
know a lot about american politics i can
talk about canada all day long i'm
really well versed in middle east stuff
uh eastern europe is not my expertise
and because we have so few trusted
sources to try to make sense of this has
been difficult that's why i had nikki
haley on that's why i had our former
ambassador to germany rick grinnell on
earlier in the week um
but you know just the way we pivot to
things i'm always more interested in the
way we consume information and the media
reaction than necessarily the stories
themselves so it's far more interesting
to me how we pivoted from covid to war
and suddenly when the war is done we're
going to pivot to something else and how
they can always keep our eye on
something else rather than what's right
in front of us that game whatever that
is is more interesting to me than like
just the basic
minutia of politics so
uh i'd say it's it's a five maybe if i'm
on a one to ten because i enjoy it and
it can also be crazy and i try not to be
consumed by it uh purdue says watch your
direct message show on monday my
question where did all the anger come
from were there always seeds of anger
and arrogance in the liberal community
so i think what you're referring to we
did the clip of the lunatics i mean
really just these crazy women on the
view basically calling for tulsi gabbard
and tucker carlson to be arrested
because they've had some thoughts
outside of the mainstream uh related to
the russia ukraine war and you know
whoopi i mean whoopi she was sane she
was decent she was a great actress
but really not only calling for tulsi to
basically be arrested but to investigate
people we used to investigate people if
we thought they had anything to do with
the russians that's what we used to do
oh was that really great when we were
doing that in the 50s when we were
trying to find communists everywhere and
who's they you know they they would do
it that's what you kept saying they used
to look into people they used to arrest
people who's they like do you trust they
i'm not that into they at the moment um
so the question about their anger though
is interesting and i think what has
really been exposed in the last two
years is that the people that purport to
be the nice ones and the tolerant ones
and the diverse ones who scream about
this well they scream about it all day
long because they're not really that but
you know they talk about rainbows and
coexistence and diversity and equity and
all of these things it's like they never
act in any of those ways when when have
you seen a lefty rally that was really
full of love and tolerance and decency
you see a lot of destruction and things
burning down and garbage everywhere
meanwhile when people on the right
generally have rallies they clean up
after themselves you know all the stuff
in canada where they were literally
shoveling streets helping old people
across the street taking care of the
garbage et cetera there is a fundamental
difference there and and that doesn't
mean that there is not any bad elements
on the right and it doesn't mean that
every
every element on the left is is so evil
but there is a fundamental difference
and the anger i think comes from
if you just believe that the world
should be the way you want it to be
because you want it to be that way and
then it doesn't happen you're gonna be
pretty pissed and that's why believing
in individual rights and choice and live
and let live uh is a much better way you
will you'll innately be happier you'll
understand that you don't own the world
and you can do your best to shape a
world that is somewhat in line with what
your views are but that you don't own
the world i don't own earth i can fight
for the things that i believe in and
hopefully make it a
a better place hopefully
but i'm not here to burn it down if i
don't but there's a lot of people that
want to
burn this country i don't want to
i wrote a book
granny says when can the audio book be
ordered i want to hear the book through
your voice p.s if you do any additional
touring can you put charlotte north
carolina on your agenda so we are going
to raleigh north carolina if you can
make it over there as for the audiobook
i am told that you can pre-order it
right now that's right if you go to
audible.com and you just search don't
burn this country you can pre-order the
audiobook i read it myself it was three
days five hours a day a lot of talking
uh but it's fun you'll you'll dig it i
really really enjoyed doing it and you
know that's where you can get a little
more a little more human and a little
more humor and a little more just me
kind of right in there
you know there's something really nice
about having a physical book you know
it's very old school to have just like a
physical thing that you can hold and
keep and hand to somebody but audio
works too so you can go to audible.com
search don't burn this country uh cheryl
says now that biden has publicly
declared putin a war criminal do you see
any way for the u.s to avoid getting
stuck in that quagmire i mean
nothing about any of this is really
making any sense to me on one hand biden
gives this you know state of the union
speech we're not going to war we're not
going to war okay but we're going to
sanction the hell out of them and then
we know that the sanctions didn't really
affect their energy sector but we're
gonna arm some people we're thinking
about the no-fly zone we're do we're
cutting them off the world monetary
system like we're doing all of these
things that in effect our war
besides just putting a tank you know
with you know with the us flag on the
border and sending it into russia so in
essence we're in some sort of proxy war
or undeclared war or something but
they're not giving putin any out here i
mean that that does seem like the weird
thing to me um and it's a little unclear
like any of the the sanctions you know
they're they're saying the russian
economy has collapsed and you know
mcdonald's isn't there anymore and
tick-tock isn't there anymore and
facebook isn't there and it's like maybe
they're winning then you know because if
we didn't have those things we'd
probably be better off
so it it's hard to decipher
where this thing really is at and and
what does war mean i guess that really
is the question in 2022
what is a war you know if this was 50
years ago you declare war on a country
you know germany declared war on its
neighbors and went into france right and
it went into the uk and then the allies
declared war on germany and wars were
fought with tanks and soldiers and
helicopters and planes and it was clear
what was happening because it was
tangible and real we now do these wars
where this is about cutting people off
from financial systems you know shutting
down pipelines
all of these things so what really is
war i don't see the out for for putin
right now i think we have to really
think about it because we should not
want world war three and you also if
putin is as crazy
as the media makes it seem that he is if
he's this you know just really
megalomaniac character in russia he
still does have nukes he still does have
nukes and ah is our policy of we're not
going to war but we are going to war is
that really scaring him or or is he sort
of duping us
i don't know
amy says how do you think becoming a
parent will influence the content of
your show and your next book it would be
interesting to come back to your answer
in a year or two from now to see how
accurate your answer was
well look it's obviously gonna change
right like that's the purpose of
parenthood that things change and there
are things outside of you that are more
important than you and the lessons that
you will learn and probably you'll learn
that your parents were right about some
stuff that you didn't think they were
right about and all that thing so i
don't know exactly what lessons i will
learn but i know that there will be
lessons
to be learned and let's remember to keep
this so that in a year or two we can
visit it when i have huge bags under my
eyes and all my hair has fallen out and
i've gained 10 pounds and i don't know
where anything is where are my keys who
did that why are you so loud like all
that stuff like it's all coming i
understand it's coming but i had a good
run 45 years people i had a good
run and uh now i've got a
banged up hip and i'm going to be a
parent
it's a hell of a i got to do something
fun this weekend you want to go to a
water park do they have water parks or
adults even allowed at water park gator
world oh we're going to go to gator
let's go to gator world this weekend
we'll see we'll see uh anya says the
kovid mania is not a thing of our past
for the power hungry bettors there are
still mandates at workplaces emergency
power is in place and talks about
digital passports how do we make sure
that the derangement ends and never
happens again
yeah
and again this is partly like the
florida thing for me where i don't see
it here and it's why i wanted to escape
cali and when i was in cali last week
taping
this prageru video that i did which will
come out i think the day before don't
burn this country comes out
um it felt very depressing there and i
walked into pan coated in the coffee
joint and they wouldn't serve me because
i didn't have a mask on and they had a
sign outside you know you can't even
come in if you don't have a vax passport
just all the stuff um how do we make
sure it doesn't happen again that really
is the question so as some of the stuff
dissipates right now the idea is in the
system that they can lock us down
whenever they want and they saw that
people don't really push back and in
some cases people really want it and
applaud it and ask for more thank you
sir may i have another so so whoever
they is and i think you get that like
it's hard to it's hard to piece this
whole damn thing together but i think
the system sees that we're we're pretty
much cheap
we're all pretty much sheep not
everybody not every state not every city
not every individual not every family
but we're all pretty much
and if they need again to put something
in the system to scare us to lock us
down why wouldn't they do it i mean you
can already feel it it feels like
they're prepping us for the next cove
there's a really weird video of bill
gates out there that you may have seen i
tweeted it yesterday about bill gates
where he's like you know the next round
of covet that'll really show him and
then he kind of smiles in this very evil
way what are these people talking about
you know so i think the way we
the way we make sure it doesn't come
back is we really have to remember who
was roughly right and who was roughly
wrong over these last two years you know
i'm not saying i was right about
everything i'm really not and and maybe
those first two weeks when they said
that 15 day thing i should have been
screaming and saying no no no no no and
i shouldn't have gone to the grocery
store with freaking gloves and a mask
and i
we all did the best we could in that fog
of war of those two weeks but but pretty
much after the two weeks i was
saying we got to open things up we're
destroying people's lives we're ruining
our urban centers just the decay of
everything that is good is right in
front of us right now um we have to
remember who who were the people that
called for mandates this whole time as
now mandates are going away and we're
realizing that they want us on fourth
and fifth boosters and all these things
like if you got everything wrong for two
years you just have to be ignored we
don't have to jail these people we don't
have to throw them in the gulag but we
have to ignore these people that's why
to flash back to the beginning of the
show the trevor noah thing it's like all
right that's great man
you kind of get it because kyrie irving
should be allowed to play but he should
have been allowed to play the entire
time and you yourself
were mocking people who were against
mandates so someone like him i guess
should be ignored more than anything
else and and not just like oh you get a
treat because you're not a complete
idiot like you're not wrong on
everything so you get a special button
or a tag a little star for your lapel i
think we have to just not forget and and
then you that it's on you to sort of
curate the people that you can roughly
trust when all hell breaks loose because
obviously all hell br is going to break
loose again it's it's in the system it
just is it just is but uh well in many
ways not to make it about the book but i
have a lot of i have a lot of answers
about this lunacy so let's promo the
book
don't burn this country is out on april
12th 2022 you can pre-order yours right
now at daverubin.com
book or you can go to audible.com and
search don't burn this country and
pre-order the audible audio version
and right now
today the pre-sale for don't burn this
country book tour is available for our
friends at reubenreport.locals.com
you can go to the locals community you
can click the link that i put there for
supporters only tickets available today
in all of the markets and tomorrow they
will be available for what we call the
general public that's the rest of you
uh i've enjoyed this q a i hope you have
as well i look forward to continuing the
conversation on all of these things with
you part two of my interview with rick
grinnell former
ambassador to germany and acting
director of national intelligence is up
on youtube and rumble the full things up
at reubenreport.locals.com absolutely ad
free that's it we got some stuff to do
today i hope you do as well
see you
tomorrow